what's fascinating um
to remember is that selma this movie
very recent didn't it came out in 2014 i
believe
yeah yeah and at the time this is just
one of those
sort of time warp moments but when that
movie came out
you and the rest of the cast you were
very vocal um
about yes how far we've come but really
how far we still need to go
[Music]
in in terms of fighting for for uh
rights
fighting for the rights of of people of
color
and you guys were very vocal about it
and at the time
there was some criticism about that
people thought look just promote the
movie
you don't have to get into all of this
and it's incredible that
in 2014 when you and the cast were
saying that
jump ahead just a few years and it feels
like
tell me your impression but it's
shocking to me that
we had to catch up to what you guys were
saying in 2014
is that how it feels to you absolutely
and playing catch-up is is what america
seems to have been doing when it comes
to race
the whole not not just you know in the
last five six
years but you know from the civil rights
movement from
you know the the civil war from the the
the times of slavery where
black people have been going this is not
okay we are human beings
please see us for who we actually are
which is
equal to you the same as you in terms of
humanity in terms of rights
in terms of just being treated fairly
and
you know that was end of 2014 beginning
of 2015 and specifically
one of the things that we were
protesting with the film
was the murder of eric garner you know
that that at that time
not unlike we just saw with george floyd
we were confronted with this image of
this man
being killed live on camera
um for selling cigarettes on on on the
on a corner which of course couldn't be
more wrong
couldn't be more shocking shouldn't be
happening anywhere in the world
let alone uh in a bastion of supposed
democracy like america
and at the premiere of the film we wore
i can't breathe t-shirts you know that
murder was the first time we heard that
that phrase become popular as it were i
shouldn't say
popular or or widely used
which is you know i can't breathe
because those were eric garner's dying
words and um so we wore these icon brief
t-shirts
at the premiere and we met with all this
backlash
how dare you do this you should just be
promoting a movie we've seen this in
sports as well shut up and dribble
or whatever yeah um and um
and it was really shocking that we we
faced that from members of the academy
you know people who thought that we were
out of line
to be to be uh to be protesting in that
way despite the fact that we had made a
film about
the injustice of voting being denied
black people
50 years ago but here we are now you
know
mike brown happened in that same kind of
time in in ferguson
so um you know the the the struggle
the struggle continues but i will say
you know
it was gratifying that we had that
opposition back then
and you know this summer just gone you
know you see
myriads of people black white every
everything in between
wearing i can't breathe t-shirts and and
you know it's become something that uh
you know it's it's harder for people to
oppose
but i will say you know this film i have
coming out this week uh come away
you know we've had backlash you know
people saying um there was one comment
um that said here we go again hollywood
trying to erase our whiteness
um and and that's because we have
in alice uh and and peter our film come
away showcases
alice from alice in wonderland and peter
from peter pan
and reimagines them as brother and
sister and because i'm their dad they
are kids of color
and um these are fictional characters
from a beloved
fairy tale nothing tied to race nothing
tight or historical figures
and people have taken some people i
should say have taken umbrage
with the idea of alice and peter being
kids
kids of color despite them being
fictional uh fantasy
characters i know you know we're still
we're still dealing with some of this
stuff yeah it's it's
that is unfortunate it may be the case
that
that unfortunately it might be a good
sign
that you're doing work that causes some
people to be a little uncomfortable
that's probably the only way you know
you're getting somewhere uh i agree
i agree and and that's how i now take it
if i if i'm honest
earlier on in my career i uh i took it
more personally
i was more hurt by it because
look we're human beings any any kind of
rejection is is something that's hard
hard to take but i absolutely agree with
you
it's you know we've seen it in this
election cycle we're seeing in culture
we saw it this summer with the black
lives matter movement
this stuff is with us but the more
it is showcased as being with us the
more we can actually deal with it
because there's nothing worse
as a black person in relation to this
stuff than feeling like you're being
gaslighted
you're you're you need to feel crazy um
really we have obama come on
you know right didn't that four uh eight
years of obama solved all of the
problems we're talking
about racism now um which uh
um sadly is i think what what some
people
truly believed or wanted to tell
themselves to feel more comfortable
about it